les commerces affichent portes closes ce
matin dans les rues de karachi
à l'instar de plusieurs transports
publics ils suivent un mouvement de
grève nationale à l'appel de leaders
religieux pour protester contre
l'attitude du gouvernement à l'égard du
tnp ce parti islamiste radicale très
influent dans le pays a pris en otage
onze policiers ce dimanche avant de
libérer ce lundi matin à l'issue de
négociations avec les autorités
une démonstration de force qui s'inscrit
dans le mouvement mené depuis une
semaine afin d'obtenir la rupture de
toute relation diplomatique avec la
france n'est xion cible des
protestations raison des propos tenus
par emmanuel macron en octobre dernier
le président français avait notamment
défendu le droit du journal satirique
charlie hebdo de publier des caricatures
du prophète de l'islam une position
considérée comme une provocation par une
partie de la population du pakistan
de leur côté les autorités pakistanaises
ont décidé de classer le parti en
question comme groupe terroriste à cause
de leur mode d'action violent ce samedi
le premier ministre a tenté de clarifier
la situation
en condamnant justement ces méthodes
laissez-moi préciser ceci à l'attention
de tous ici et à l'étranger
notre gouvernement est intervenu contre
le tlp en vertu des lois antiterroristes
quand ils ont contesté l'autorité de
l'état ont fait usage de la violence et
ont attaqué la population et les forces
de l'ordre depuis la semaine dernière le
tnp a été officiellement interdit et
plusieurs de ses membres auraient été
tués d'après plusieurs chefs du
mouvement ce dimanche une journée de
protestation particulièrement violence
lors de laquelle des affrontements ont
eu lieu entre protestataires et forces
de sécurité la police a tout de suite
commencé à pilonner et a tiré des balles
directement sur nous nos garçons ont été
blessés certains ont reçu des balles
dans la poitrine
d'autres ont reçu des balles dans la
tête nous ne sommes pas armés
ils ont martyrisé des dizaines de nos
hommes
nous sommes désarmés nous n'avons que
l'amour du prophète
rien d'autre nous voulons qu'ils nous
tirent dessus ou qu'ils expulsent
l'ambassadeur français parce que rien
n'est plus important pour nous que
l'honneur du prophète
malgré leur interdiction les violences
les membres du tnp entendent bien
poursuivre leur mobilisation contre la
france une manifestation d'ampleur à
l'appel du parti est prévue ce mardi
pour faire à nouveau pression sur le
gouvernement pakistanais